so this is the other photo and i'll give
you some context over it
first of all the sound is very very
different it's actually very quiet and
not as chaotic and we realized that the
really loud scratching crazy sounds that
you heard were added in to create a
scary effect this is actually quite calm
if you listen to it
yeah and then tommy pushes him first
that wasn't in it
and then tommy does this which he didn't
want aired anyone to see
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products the website is in
the description link below you can also
use a discount code salam 10 for 10
of their products okay so three years
ago tommy uploaded his most viral video
which is what uh really happened when a
migrant attack it's got 2.1 million
views
and it's four minutes long and we can
just watch parts of it just to
we've only been in the area for mere
minutes when the migrants hanging around
began to notice the camera
one of them even going for my camera
so this is where it all starts to get
really fake but i'll explain that in a
second
george is filming but i don't
know what happened
really intense there's
static noise that's added fake
[Music]
why are there people saying that um this
is just people being like why did you
why did you hit him what's going on
because it looks like in that video and
we'll show you in the other version it
looks like that guy has just seen the
camera i've gotten really handy i'll be
honest if i was watching this as someone
from a neutral side not fire anyone i'll
be like he did a good job like in the
context where he was like you know he
went there a a journalist would be an
attack on her her screams and he goes
like a brave man like a hero he goes
there and this guy's coming to attack
him saying i'm going to take you alive
and he hits him i would justify
everything you know if you think about
the way when you look at it from this
angle but that's not what really
happened no and this is what i gave to
the independent and um and what byline
time spoke about as well and they
dissected it and it's a little bit
complicated but i'll go through exactly
what it was like so this is the rule so
this is this so this raw footage guys is
basically
what really happened yeah and and it's
and you know it's it's it amazes you how
like you know with editing and adding a
few subtitles and changing a few things
how it changes the whole paradigm
there's a paradigm shift of actually
what happened you know
it's crazy man and this is this is
exactly what um isis does you know with
their videos that for example certain
attacks that happen in certain places
like look muslim women tried you know we
can do the same thing these guys do
exactly the same thing look a muslim
woman dragged a christ church attack
bang bang bang bang bang we need to
stand up
there you go that is radicalization
right there because people are emotional
or they're attacking our sisters for no
reason you know we need to do something
about it and this is this is how they
recruit yeah same exact method that's
why i say these guys are no different to
isis that's the same thing man use the
same methods of marketing to recruit and
let your soldiers carry their attacks up
so this is the other photo and i'll give
you some context over it first of all
the sound is very very different it's
actually very quiet and not as chaotic
and we realized that the really loud
scratching crazy sounds that you heard
were added in to create a scary effect
this is actually quite calm if you
listen to it
yeah and then tommy pushes him first
that wasn't in it
and then tommy does this which he didn't
want aaron anyone to see
was unprovoked basically that was just
like he was just talking to him and if
you put that in context yeah now i would
be like well hold on a second you just
push the guy face down on towards the
car it's going it's gonna it's not gonna
be good for his narrative no and then
that guy obviously was furious and
that's what led to the assault actually
happening uh whereas it looks like he
just did it because yeah that's how it
seemed yeah so then they get into an
argument they get into a confrontation
he's drunk this guy this is this is how
tommy riled him up all this guy was
doing was just being drunk outside the
shop like kind of laughing with his
friends and then tommy was going up to
them this isn't on camera being like why
are you drinking in the street it's
illegal to drink in the street just just
confronting him and it's a perfect
friend look a black migrant yeah drunk
you know everything that you would want
and you're provoking and provoking him
and it's just you it's not going down um
central london finding a drunk guy let's
start picking on him and he comes he's
gonna hit you and you smack him
that's exactly what he's done yeah it's
unbelievable completely
and he's really distressed he's like
covered in the
drink from when he pushed him in front
of the car
look he's seen my
clothes and you see it's actually much
quieter and even this is full of volume
and this guy is all is he saying is keep
your life which means keep yourself to
yourself
but tommy's twisting it to make it seem
like he's like i could kill you but i'll
let you keep your life all of this this
is this is why it was
okay tell me if i'm right or wrong
where is this
uh this is in italy italy if you guys
went all the way to italy
you want a content like this or it's a
waste of journey correct me if i'm right
wrong yeah yeah because to its narrative
if you're going somewhere there has to
be drama wherever this guy goes for some
reason like he gets into some kind of a
fight so to go all the way to italy this
is this has to be worth it so to me it
seems as if he's that cocky man if i go
all the way to italy and just show a few
people sleeping on the roads people are
going to sympathize with these people
maybe i'll be like you know what yeah
you know so he said i know a provocative
drunkard let me pick on her that's how
he seems to literally it's unbelievable
who the [__] do you think you are he's
not even your country to do that who do
you think you are oh hold on a second
hold on a second he's drunk he's outside
he's causing nuisance what's the god do
where he's from yeah any drunk guy i
don't have any drunk people they just
called nuisance i don't go to be like
you know where you from uh
what's what's got to do where he's from
he's bloody drunk yeah and there wasn't
even nuisance he was just like swaying
outside the shop like okay if it was a
british born individual what are you
going to say tomorrow you're brave yeah
you can cause a nuisance you're from our
country mate yeah you you're migrant
you're not allowed to cause
he didn't want that in the video as well
that's not in the final video because
that's like really far like i don't
blame him because it would have looked
really bad yeah
i know i am okay yeah
he's just saying like you're crazy you
push me in front of a car like why would
you do that just because i'm a bit drunk
keep yourself to yourself but the
subtitle said kill yourself which is not
true
whatever you're doing or making money
it's your life
you understand
you're
he said make money go and live your life
like do what you want to do but tommy's
wanting to turn it into almost like it's
threats
and then he punches him and then but it
made it but he put that at the beginning
to make it look like he just like why
not said kill yourself i'm gonna um yeah
and this night tommy's really worried
because the police come
look other people are like what are you
doing you can't do that yeah oh that's
another bit you know how that guy's like
you cannot you cannot he put that before
the punch to make it look like that the
reaction from the other migrants was
aggressive when that was them responding
to him so it but it's reversed yes
if it was self-defense anyone the public
would have not been like that they would
just be like okay this guy was drunk he
tried to walk to him and he hit him not
that deep but you can see the public
like come on man you provoked that and
then you punch him yeah and for some
reason this guy told me always punches
his drunk people i think that's the only
kind of people we can knock out
yeah it seems like and you see how now
he's upset and he's like he's like
coming towards a bit that again if you
watch the video that went out that's at
the beginning to make it look like he's
just crazy out of control
but it's very different if you watch
this the police yeah the police are
trying to calm everything down
and these people are outraged so like
why on earth would you do that
did you get arrested uh no
but if the police saw this footage then
he would have been
he might even get banned from italy if
this goes publicly because it's like
it was genuinely an unprovoked assault
to push him in front of the car
it's unbelievable yeah unbelievable it's
a completely different video
and imagine if he has the capabilities
to do that in this video how many more
videos did he do that and made it seem
as if he's the innocent person yeah in
it and you need to understand that
some people might be like okay so what
no
this narrative is what causes innocent
people you know like for him his
propaganda uh to be spread out you know
people don't understand these kind of
videos is what's causing people to go
out there build trust for him so
everything he says people believe you
know and then i'll be honest with you i
have no doubt the christchurch attacker
watched his videos no damn doubt about
it for him to build a rage but to see
this and be like look what they're doing
and see him as some kind of a hero i
don't like it's unbelievable but he
would make a lot of money if a video
went viral and if he painted this image
of himself as like this hero that comes
in the donations went through the roof
with the exposure that i did this week
it was like half a million that's what
i'm saying to caitlin is the reason why
he's going to italy he needs to make it
worth the while yeah and he needs this
content because i'll be honest if i was
like inclined to the far right i'm damn
donating to the the video that you
showed me i'm 100 guys a hero going to
italy confronting these migrants he
tries to attack him hits him justified i
would 100 support if you showed me this
it could change my mind would yeah and
it wouldn't have gone viral and it
wouldn't work exactly and you see how
radicalism happens because as as if i
have far inclination and i'm seeing this
i'm going to get more radicalized i'm
going to be
storage supporter office you just see
the ripple effects man in our society
these these actions you know what they
caused
and like one thing as well as tommy and
a couple of the far-right people i was
working with at the time would always
joke that it's actually if you want to
go to a real no-go zone with a camera
you go to a white neighborhood that's
poor in poland where they'll literally
like just steal the camera and yeah
that's like the most dangerous but they
they literally knew all of that but they
were like this is what cells would not
make money especially with their sharia
no goes on something
i was i didn't want to laugh or cry over
i hope people watching this at home you
know realize you know that these people
they don't they don't care about you i'm
being honest with him isis yeah they
don't care about it they have an agenda
they want to sue that and they're just
recruiting you guys via these videos why
these propaganda videos get you
emotional get you you know
and and jump on board and they'll just
use you you know and you're the one
who's gonna go suffer your child your
children are going to be the ones who
are going to go in the front lines and
trying to run over a
non-muslim or run over a muslim and like
i said before it's like people like me
who's suffering i have to wash my back
okay who's going to come you have to
watch your back
sad yeah
thank you my thanks for your attention
no it's an absolute pleasure you too
thank you